when my young day was not really
possible to do a degree in computer
science about two years after I'd
actually enrolled for chemistry computer
science degrees did become available but
you know you're talking in mid 60's so I
wasn't quite in the first generation of
computer scientists in the forties but I
was in the early second-generation
something like that I started out with
chemistry and even at that stage I mean
we are talking 1967-68 they early
computers were being used a lot in
physics and in chemistry for doing
calculations on molecules and stuff like
that that's how I got into computing
yeah how do you make that jump from just
using this as a useful tool to becoming
as all-consuming a passion or career
well I think this was something that
could happen easily in the early days
less so now we used nowadays to having
macintoshes and Windows with everything
provided for us and layers of software
in the early days you were right near
the bare metal getting these things to
run fast enough close to the hardware so
you had to be aware bit like driving an
early automobile in the early days you
couldn't rely on an automatic gearbox
you had to know how to change gear it
was the same with the early computers
and got more mesmerised in terms of
keeping the things working and not
crashing and how all that happened
that's how it began
I was fortunately enough to end up doing
my quantum chemistry in a mathematics
department which had if you like an
embryonic interest in computers a lot of
people like me came from the physical
sciences and really you know quite
delighted and being able to do their
calculations on the computer some of
them as I've also indicated came from
mathematical logic and that sort of
thing and they work quite well with
electronics engineers doing hands and
ores and stuff like this but even in
those very early days art space people
were very very influential what would I
bring
they were bringing in the case of
English language and linguistic
specialists the idea of the fact that
computer languages are like simplified
versions of natural languages you know
just as you were well maybe you weren't
made to pause English sentences into
nouns adjectives and verbs but I
certainly was and they just fell
naturally for this so yeah
languages like Fortran Java C they have
a syntax and anybody who's being brought
up in an English language environment
just relates that straight away does
that still happen today that people from
music and languages and the arts are
drawn to computers was it more separated
now I think it is still the case
although I'm talking about my own
experience many years ago now I found
the easiest people from the arts faculty
teach were musicians and English
language specialists musicians because
they used the notation and you get a lot
of that in computer science used to
reading it interpreting it and so on and
like I said the English people because
they were absolutely at home when I said
what you've written in the algal
language looks sensible but it isn't
legal it isn't syntactic draw a chart
and tell me why it isn't they could just
do that standing on their head
he's computer science now like it was
then what has changed massively is that
when I started computers were not a
commodity yeah they absolutely were not
they cost millions they were in
air-conditioned basements and those are
sort of priesthood that had to tend to
the things what has made our lives as
computer scientists very rich and
wonderful but also massively difficult
is that they've become a commodity my
colleagues in chemistry do not have to
worry that your average amateur is going
to be able to want to convict a nuclear
explosion yeah nor the physicists have
to start worrying about magnetic
resonance imaging for amateurs one of
those machines cost tens of millions but
in computing you can get a decent
computer for 50 quid now
and so in a way it's wonderful because
what the underlying things are still
there and there are still leading edge
things to be done on getting tablets to
work making them fast enough making sure
they don't drain the batteries doing the
software for the apps all of that but
it's all targeted in the end very
largely towards making these things
desirable commodities and the problem
with that is that once you've got into
that situation you become a target at
parties at a cocktail party you should
never be a medic a lawyer or a computer
scientist but you'll be backed into a
corner and it's either my leg hurts
what's wrong or my neighbor is doing
this how do I sue him or in my case it's
listen have you got Windows 7 now I'm
all release three now I pressed if you
know you just got a smile and enjoy it
and you also got to be prepared to admit
I just don't know